the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i would like to discuss
what actress maisie williams said during
one of her interviews for the hollywood
reporter
now before i go any further i just have
to say this is not breaking news
i want to make sure everyone knows this
article wasn't released yesterday
maisie williams actually sat down for
this interview a few months ago but i
somehow completely missed this
information until now there is a chance
some of you are already aware of this
and i would have already made a video
about it if i had known it was revealed
but i haven't seen any of you mentioned
this on my videos either so maybe some
of you don't know
i just had to make a video about this
because it directly relates to something
i have discussed before
i think i would be doing a disservice to
all of you if i never mentioned this
myself so let's get into it
when maisie williams sat down for this
interview she dropped a massive
bombshell about the final season
what she said basically confirmed what a
lot of us were already thinking but
that's not the only reason why i'm
making the video
i think what she said does give us a
better indication of where george rr
martin will end his books
now i don't want to say it confirms
anything for a fact but i believe
it does especially when you consider all
of the foreshadowing that's already been
laid out
let me read what was said during the
interview then i will explain exactly
what i mean
in the article maisie williams reveals
what should have happened during the
night king's original ending
it says nearly 16 months after the
series finale of game of thrones
williams may have added a new wrinkle to
the season's most enduring moment
as well as its biggest swerve which saw
arya stark strike the fatal blow to the
series big bad
she said actor kit harrington expected
it to go jon snow's way
and he even said it should have went
that way all the way back in season 3
he said someone told him jon snow would
be the one who would kill the night king
this is what he thought would happen for
the remainder of the series
that is until he read the script for the
final season the writers did not bother
letting him know about the new direction
they were heading in beforehand
dan and dave most likely wanted to see
his reaction in front of everyone else
that's like a slap in the face if you
ask me
now he never did say who told him he
would kill the night king all he said
was they told him that during the third
season
i'm assuming it was the writers who gave
him this information although i don't
know that for sure
i just think it had to be someone high
up though otherwise he wouldn't have
believed it for so long
thankfully we do have video evidence of
his first reaction when finding out arya
would kill the night king instead of him
she vaults off a pile of dead whites
leaps at the night king
and she plunges the dagger up through
the night king's armor and the night
king shatters
now we do see him crack a little smile
during that read-through
but happiness wasn't the only emotion he
felt he did later reveal that he was
upset about the change of direction
and i don't blame him either i would
have been upset as well
now this is only speculation but i bet
he felt somewhat betrayed
i would almost guarantee way back in
season 3 when he found out he would be
the one who would kill the night king
it wasn't just some offhand remark i
doubt one of the writers simply said
you're gonna kill the night king then
just walked away
they most likely had a conversation
about it and maybe even a sit down of
their own
where they explained why jon snow would
kill the night king
over the next four or five years he went
on believing that's how it would end
now this is how he really felt when he
found out who would kill the night king
the actor said i was a bit pissed off
only because i wanted to kill the night
king
i think i felt like everyone else did in
that it had been set up for a long time
and then i didn't get to do it
but i was so happy for maisie and arya
he's absolutely right they had been
foreshadowing jon vs the night king from
the very beginning
now where do you think this information
was from maisie williams found this out
from harrington
and he found this out from one of the
writers in my opinion but where did they
get the information
was it their own original idea before
they changed it or was it from george
and if it was from george will this
happen in his books
well if and that's a big if if i'm right
about this information coming from dan
and dave
then i bet this was originally from
george himself
remember kid harrington said he found
out jon would kill the night king back
in season 3 before the night king was
even introduced
well this is right around the same time
dan and dave learn how george would end
his books
let me break it down for you all the way
back in 2014
dan and dave sat down for an interview
and this is when they revealed they knew
how things would end
let me show you exactly what they said
when they were interviewed by vanity
fair
they said last year we went out to santa
fe for a week to sit down with george rr
martin
and just talk through where things are
going because we don't know if we are
going to catch up and where exactly that
would be
if you know the ending then you can lay
the groundwork for it
and so we want to know how everything
ends we want to be able to set things up
remember what they're saying here they
sat down with george so they could know
his ending
because they wanted to be able to set
things up for the ending as soon as they
could
then they go on to say so we just sat
down with him and literally went through
every character
george rr martin said i can give them
the broad strokes of what i intend to
write but the details aren't there yet
i'm hopeful that i cannot let them catch
up with me so george basically gave them
the endings of the main characters but
he didn't know everything these
characters would go through to get there
keep in mind dan and dave sat down for
this interview back in march of 2014
and during this interview they said they
had their little sit down with george
last year
that means they found out the ending all
the way back in 2013.
they learned that in 2013 in actor kit
harrington said
he learned of jon snow's ending during
season 3.
well what do you know season 3 aired
back in 2013
the same year dan and dave had their sit
down with george rr martin
now i'm speculating here but i would bet
jon snow's ending originated from this
meeting
george gave the info to dan and dave in
2013 that dan and dave gave the info to
the actors during season 3.
if you remember this is how actor isaac
hempstead wright
found out bran stark would be the king
in the books as well
he knew the info was from george himself
because dana dave said that's where they
got it from
it wasn't until a few years after they
had this meeting with george when they
decided
you know what we don't like that ending
we don't want jon snow killing the night
king because it's obvious
although it should be obvious by the
final season because they had been
setting it up that way for nearly a
decade
that's the whole reason they had to sit
down at george's anyway
they said they needed to know how it
ended so they could start setting things
up in the following seasons
this is also why kid harrington still
believed he would kill the night king
because it was always set up that way
now i'm sure you've all seen the inside
the episode by now
but that was when dan and dave admitted
they changed it on their own
we hoped to kind of avoid the expected
and jon snow has always been the hero
the one who's been the savior but it
just didn't seem right to us for this
for this moment
we knew it had to be valerian steel
[Music]
for oh god i think it's probably three
years now or something we've known
that it was going to be arya who
delivers that that fatal blow
they never said george doesn't like that
ending they said
we don't like that ending as in dan and
dave they decided they wanted arya to
kill the night king around season six
or roughly three years before the final
season aired
remember there were some big gaps in
between those last few seasons
dan and dave did the exact thing george
r martin said you should never do as a
writer
they betrayed their own story in more
than one way
and then the other one was of course
some you know i have certain things that
i'm laying clues for that there'll be
revelations later on
some people had put together those clues
even as early as 1998 or adding things
together
i said well what what do i do with that
what do i do with that
yeah these people have guessed the
secret that i'm going to reveal in book
six
people have already guessed that here
and book two is just out
you really have two choices there you
can ignore it and proceed with your plan
despite the fact that some people know
where you're going
or you can get all panicky and say oh my
god they figured it out i can't let that
be i'll have to change it i'll have to
go in a different direction
and i think some writers do that and i
think that's always a mistake
yeah you know if you've planned your
book that the butler did it
and then you read an internet someone
has figured out that the butler did it
and you suddenly change in mid-stream
and it was the chambermaid who did it
then you screw up the whole book because
you get these just foreshadowing early
on and you've got these little clues you
planted now they're dead ends and
you have to introduce other clues and
you're retconning it's a mess so
i decided as early as dragon's
dragonstone's heyday i would stay off
the fan sites and and let the
let those be for the fans let those be
for the readers let them argue their
theories
whether they're right whether they're
wrong now i do realize some of you are
sick of hearing about this argument over
who should have killed the night king
i get it believe me i do there are some
things i'm sick of hearing about
but i will never forgive them for this i
can't believe i'm just now seeing this
interview where maisie williams revealed
the information
although some of us already knew this i
still believe it is a massive revelation
because this might be how george will
end his story
assuming he is the one who gave this
info to dane and dave
and then dan and dave were the ones who
gave it to kid arrington
now there is not a night king in the
books at least not yet
in the books we do hear stories about
the original night's king who ruled the
night fort thousands of years ago but we
have yet to see if there is an actual
leader of the white walkers
i realize i might be alone on this but i
absolutely believe the white walkers do
have a leader
now whether that leader is just another
white walker or a blood raven or an
ancient member of the children of the
forest is still to be seen
whatever the case may be i do think
there is a leader who will be revealed
in the winds of winter
and based on everything i've read in the
books i think jon snow will be the one
who ultimately stops them
he won't do it alone obviously but he
will be the x factor
i feel like the foreshadowing has been
there from the very beginning
just like it was in the show it seems
obvious now because we've all been
discussing it for years and thanks to
the internet
things spread like wildfire and live on
forever
since so many of us have been discussing
it for so long there are now some fans
who no longer like the idea
of john killing the night king the same
way there are some fans who got sick of
hearing about the rlj
theory but like george said just because
someone figures it out
doesn't mean you scramble and freak out
then go back and change it
you cannot do that otherwise it ruins
your story
so now we know jon should have killed
the night king
but for some dumb and dumber reason dan
and dave thought they had a better idea
instead
as you all know i was so invested in the
northern storylines
i could go on about this for hours but i
don't want to do that
i only wanted to give my thoughts on
this subject because although it is very
frustrating
it is an interesting reveal as well let
me know what all of you have to say
about it
do you think this is how george wants
john's story to end
and where do you think this info came
from leave your thoughts down below
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching my video and supporting the
channel
have a great day i will see you soon bye
[Music]
so
you